ربما لم يسمع احد بمستوطنه عيلي الصغيره
وسط الضفه الغربيه قبل اليوم لكنها تحولت
الى موقع حدث سيذكره المستوطنون جيدا بعد
الان على الطريق بين رام الله ونابلس يعيش
5000 اسرائيلي في المستوطنه المقامه على
اراضي قرن فلسطينيه شمال رام الله جنوب
نابلس يصل شاب فلسطيني ببندقيه واحده الى
مدخل المستوطن هناك تمت محطه وقود يترجل
الشاب ويطلق النار ليقتل اربعه مستوطنين
على الاقل ويصيب اربعه اخرين من المسافه
الصفر قبل ان يقتله مستوطن مسلح ككل
المستوطنين في الضفه الغربيه لكن من اين
جاء الشهيد وفق الروايات فان المنفذه جاء
من القرى الجنوبيه لمدينه نابلس وتحديدا
من قريه حواره على بعد عشرين كيلو مترا
الى الشمال من لا يعرف حواره تلك القريه
التي دعا وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي الى
محوها بعد ساعات قليله من قيام مستوطنين
بالفعل بادرام النار في عشرات المنازل
ممتلكات بالقريه في سياقات المكان والزمان
لا تبدو الضفه الغربيه متاثره بالضربات
الاسرائيليه خلال الاشهر القليله الماضيه
تلك ضربات قتلت قرابه 170 فلسطينيا منذ
بدايه العام بينهم عشرات مسلحين ترتكز
الاقتحامات الاسرائيليه شبه اليوميه على
منطقتين نابلس وجنين بشكل خاص مع تصاعد
ظاهره المقاومه المسلحه في المدينتين
عمليه عليجات بعد 24 ساعه فقط من ضربه
قويه تلقاها جيش الاحتلال في جنين من هناك
عجز احد اقوى جيوش المنطقه لساعات عن سحب
قواته والياته المعطبه بفعل عبوات محليه
الصنع على ذكر العبوات محليه الصنع تلفت
عمليه عيدي النظر الى القدرات العسكريه
الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه الحديث عن
اسلحه خفيفه لا تتجاوز المسدسات وبنادق
الكلاشنكوف او الام 16 لا حديث عن صواريخ
مضاده للدروع او الطيران ولا الغام
النوعيه لا حديث عن ملاجئ او خنادق او
مناطق حدوديه الحديث فقط عن قرار
بالمقاومه ذلك قرار يبدو انها استطاع
تجاوز العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
المكثفه في الضفه الغربيه كما استطاع
تجاوز العقبات امام الحصول على اسلحه تكفي
لابقاء اسرائيل
متاهبه على الدوام